Nirvana but Charles Bukowski not much
chance completely cut loose from purpose
it was a young man riding a bus to North
Carolina on the way to somewhere and
they began to snow and the bus stopped
at a little cafe in the hills and the
passengers entered and he sat at the
counter with the others and he ordered
the food arrived and the meal was
particularly good and the coffee
the waitress
like the women he had known she was
unaffected and there was a natural humor
which came from her and the fry cooks
had crazy things and a dishwasher in the
back laughed the good clean pleasant
laugh and the young man watched the snow
through the window and he wanted to stay
in that cafe forever the curious feeling
swept through him that everything was
beautiful there and it would always stay
beautiful there and then the bus driver
told the passengers that it was time to
board and the young man thought I'll
just stay here I'll just stay here
and then he rose and he follow the
others into the bus he found a seat and
looked at the cafe through the window
and then the bus moved off Don a curve
downward out of the hills and the young
man looked straight forward and he heard
the other passengers speaking of other
things or they were reading or trying to
sleep and they hadn't noticed the magic
and the young man put his head to one
side close his eyes and pretended to
sleep there was nothing else to do just
to listen to the sound of the engine and
the sound of the tires in the snow
you